they were made with cheddar but she
expected something better
so will this cheese bait and switch make
this plaintiff rich
yes it must be time for
hey the wrong kind of cheese is in these
what is this mozzarella gate
very clever huh a woman named Amy Joseph
has sued TGI Fridays after purchasing a
so-called mozzarella stick snack from
Amazon only to find that it doesn't
contain mozzarella but only cheddar
also they aren't really sticks
like when I give panhandlers Canadian
coins
joke's on you dirt bags huh
she filed the lawsuit last year but a
federal judge uh Robert Dow I thought
the name has since ruled that although
TGI Fridays is not to blame because it's
license its name the suit can move
forward Against The Snack Maker which is
known as inventure Foods
now if true they sullied Friday's good
name like the city of Chicago does to
the band Chicago
why did I need to know the judge's name
that was so stupid the plaintiff had
purchased a six-pack of the snacks for
22.95 which is the kind of purchase most
people only admit to in a therapist's
office
of course this is the first time people
are filing such lawsuits against food
companies just last week we told you
about someone suing Velveeta because
their shells and cheese took longer than
three and a half minutes to make like
the Box intended
and who can forget the Pop-Tarts Saga
strawberry pastries without real
strawberries right and I'm actually
suing Reese's Peanut Butter Cups turns
out they aren't made from Reese's
monkeys
[Applause]
where's the joy of sinking my teeth into
a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup if it's not
a monkey cat if it's not a monkey why am
I doing this
[Laughter]
I think that I've been living my life
all wrong
I always thought hard work was what was
important you work really hard you know
have some success make some money I that
was wrong you gotta sue people sue
people I I've been spending too much
time at my desk not enough time at the
vending machine just buying snacks and
reading the label you know it you know
it I got pre-lawsuit spending three
lawsuits uh uh Jiffy Pop right right
because it just it's a it's just a mess
Jiffy Pop is a mess uh Imodium I'm suing
them for their little packaging oh yeah
Ashley's quick it never looks like the
chocolate milk they claim it is Emily
who do you want to sue you're a lawyer I
bet it's easy to sue for you you just
wake up in the morning yeah file a
lawsuit in your pajamas
I just here's the thing so also Kona
Brewing and that Texas barbecue sauce
the list goes on sketch what that sketch
doesn't look like anything it's a sketch
the list goes on but the list goes on it
does and it will go on I I find it just
as annoying as you guys because It
embarrasses me that that's part of my
profession however
just to be the contrarian here it does
serve a purpose in that we have to be
true to our marketing right so if this
said mozzarella sticks and the inside
was something totally crazy and
different right it serves a purpose to
keep those those companies in line but
all of these examples to me waste our
tax dollars that are paying for these
court fees because even though the
parties pay there's an element that our
tax dollars do right you know uh Jamie I
want to keep your emotions separate
because I understand that Fridays is the
place where you drop off the kids uh to
meet their new cool stepdad the
bartender
I was
I was thinking that this could be a
great way for you to earn back the money
you lost in the divorce
and the last time I dropped him off it
was a Monday that's false advertising
this is
dude I love this story so much and I
heard about it even before today because
I subscribed to lawsuit weekly
funny if you really think about that
this TGI Friday's in like this price
it's been around for like 50 years
someone finally looked at the
ingredients yeah like people that eat
mozzarella sticks they're banking on you
not looking at the ingredients and
that's why I think you sign a contract
when you eat mozzarella sticks I think
it should be able to say under
ingredients you don't want to know yeah
by the way they look different cheddar
is yellow and mozzarella is white
cheddar what there's white cheddar you
guys oh well maybe if you're a racist
everything's got to be white with you
Emilia everything's got to be white
[Laughter]
it's disgusting Chris that I work with
people like that no what's disgusting is
the idea that somebody goes on to Amazon
and buys a six pack of mozzarella are
these Frozen are these what are they it
says baked I mean are these like uh what
oh if I if I wanted a mozzarella stick
the last place in the world I would go
is Amazon
it was like deep fried caterpillars I
mean honestly I I should they no TGI
Fridays should sue this woman
[Laughter]
use of Amazon because if you really if
you want a mozzarella stick why the f
are you on Amazon
I used to love Fridays remember before
Fridays there was no restaurants for
young people right yeah
no you only went to restaurants with
your parents for on your birthday and it
was like a place that had like red
tablecloths all the other the other
places
yes it's the first bed again okay like
great first you had Fridays I think you
had better kids then you had Ruby
Tuesday then you had the Mexican
restaurants
[Applause]
foreigners used to have half-price apps
yeah Fridays is the original app store
yes
that really killed the mood okay
I loved Fridays man best